Eli it's Ross Tucker I'm in for Dan
today always good to talk with you and I
want to get into the commercials I just
watched first I saw the one where you're
in a banana suit the one way you're
doing karaoke says nobody ever asked me
to do a commercial what's that like mean
what how long does it take to film those
things when do you do it no closest
Mercer's are done sometime you know in
soon or and a kind of during the
offseason when you got a little bit more
free time and so it usually takes about
a participating on the one I think you
know one day about eight hours you know
you kind of knock it out in a day and so
it's not too bad you they're pretty fun
somebody at the improv the moment you
saw a banana suit on it's always
interesting you know it kind of goes to
that and and do a single little karaoke
so I was I was probably the same karaoke
that day anyway so might as well as for
the camera so way man Eli you film them
all in one day didn't take eight hours
for the 15 second banana suit thing did
it no yeah everything everything was
done in one day you know so you know the
banana suit so it took uh you know 45
minutes or whatever did not it did not
take all yeah all right well I know
you're in camp right now and you got I
don't know if your meetings go till nine
or ten or whatever have you had a chance
to watch any Olympics half I've uh you
know gotten got it we get done with
meetings around nine o'clock and and you
know usually kind of head back to the
hotel room and got to watch some of the
swimming see michael phelps went a few
few events have two assaults i'll be a
hundred meter you know run the other day
you say both winning that one and so
yeah I've got you know it's getting a
little bit of the gymnastics but yeah I
definitely kept up also during the day
maybe at lunch you might be a TV oh I'm
kind of watching watching some of the
some of the events so you know big fan
of the Olympics and what you like
watching all the Antilles compete with
deadly route infer for the USA there and
you can get
the gold hey you know where this awful
you know you know I don't think I ever
asked you this or heard this did you
play any other sports growing up and
when did you stop playing them yeah I
played I played a basketball all through
high school play baseball up until about
my junior year you know just got too
much playing three sports is really i
would have played you know by tomorrow
it was the summer that got me you know i
wanted to play the baseball team i had
to play into summer leagues i was
playing so fast bald and trying to train
up football and I was just you know I
was already a skinny kid trying to gain
weight and I just couldn't I had to drop
one just so I was always home from seven
am-10 p.m. at night they'll playing free
sports that day and I just couldn't
always finish he'll go with it so I'm a
big supporter playing multiple sports
these young kids playing different
sports don't believe in this be in focus
on 101 activity only I know some sports
a may require that but he'll pick a lot
of them you need that break you need to
rest your rest potty train your body
different ways in other sports and I
thought playing a basketball made me a
better football player just still
functioning on jumping you know doing
doing different things and I enjoyed I
do explain the basketball baseball grown
up what kind of hoops Hooper were you
you know I was okay in hoops you know I
was you know this country as part of the
system though you know I could score 25
in a game and you know the next game I
not I might not take a shot and so um
you know I was kind of a show hey get my
free throws I like my layout my jump
shot but one thing I wouldn't take it
any three quarters and I could get open
without the ball had a little inside
game and play good defense so I enjoy
enjoy basket for a lot and we are you
know good teams and enjoyed those
friendships but uh you know I can't I
can make some place I wasn't I want the
comet of fire by any means I saw you lie
you didn't play in the first preseason
game the other night
how does that conversation go down with
you and coach because I know how you are
and your brother is about getting you
know as many reps as you possibly can
was that a conversation that you and
coach McAdoo had or he just said hey I
don't want to play yeah he told me
earlier in the week you said hey you
know you're not don't play this week you
would get enough rest to me the second
and third preseason game and so I said
okay you know i didn't i didn't argue
much with them they're all we've been
fined plan but i have played in a lot in
a lot of games i can i do believe you i
can get I can get mine I my share of
preseason work in these next news next
game do you feel like Eli you still get
as much time with coach McAdoo now as
you did before I know he really helped
you in the offense was good the last
couple years but when he's a head coach
he's got a lot of other other things on
his plate yeah he definitely has other
other things going on but see I still
get to get a lot of time is still in the
school back room a good bit to have
questions forum that okay you know like
and i can text to them I can you know I
kinda have have saved you written down
to ask them but you know yeah absolute
idiot dolphins corner hit other
responsibilities he wasn't always in
every meeting every time and so uh coach
Coach Sullivan is the offensive
coordinator now have a great
relationship with him years here last
year so he was here back in you know
well / 2011 with the giant who support
that code for few of those years and so
I can then sinks ignited it is a
quarterback coach so all those guys can
handle something are all the questions
sort of simply let you know so what a
few days I've been and get hit the pool
so Eli is Payton missing training camp
at all those are you enjoying the time
off you know I felt through a little bit
I think he's I think he staying busy I
think he's traveling around some and I
think he's looking forward to a fault
you know I've never had a fall before of
you know of freedom and so I think I
don't know what it's like I think he
didn't really know it's like either but
I think he's looking forward so catching
some Giants games going to some yo Paco
games full games from university of
tennessee game so he's gonna be
traveling around I know now he'll
definitely watching The Times gave
there's no reason he won't know he has
directv and no he has the NFL Sunday
Ticket so you know every guy's game will
be on in Denver whoever he is he came
through his phone and I've made sure he
knows all the possibilities to watch our
games and expect a full recap and maybe
an essay about what he thought about
each phone to make sure he's watching
nice i was going to ask you that i'm
glad you answered that for me Eli thanks
for the time man all right hey
appreciated thanks so much the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience